okay so
so yosha i was asking what's the
difference between what you just
mentioned and the multiverse idea which
is something akin to
whatever can exist whatever is possible
exists in some way shape or form in some
other universe
i think that the multiverse in the
avraham villagram
version this idea that there is uh
basically at every
decision of the quantum
collapse the collapse of the wave
function the universe splits into copies
of itself is a slightly different
conception it's basically a mathematical
paradigm that describes that the
universe is branching
in ways that
parts of the description of the universe
no longer causally influence the other
parts of the description of the universe
imagine yet you are describing the world
as
something like a cellular automaton
and uh
in the cellular automaton you have
particles interaction interactions which
might be like gliders in the game of
life like these regular patterns that
might influence each other and change
state and move through the topology of a
space that you define in a certain way
and uh
it this thing is defined in such a way
that the computation of the entire thing
is very inefficient because it at every
step
the thing splits up into many many sub
topologies in which
you have copies of these sliders or
variants of these sliders moving about
in different ways but only a subset of
the gliders is going to influence the
others so from the perspective of the
future of this of any kind of system
the only things that are real to you are
those that can costly influence you
and if something
moves away from you in a way that it can
no longer causally influence you and
because it's no longer occupying the
same space in a way
but we basically have a space with a
dimensionality that increases and
increases and increases
and
this might look like it's extremely
wasteful but that's only from the
perspective
of somebody who is outside of the system
and cares about one of the timelines of
the system
and we only exist visit one of those
trajectories inside and for us
we would only experience a smaller and
smaller fraction of the resulting
computation at every moment
and
or in the future as a in potentia and
this is in some sense what this
multiverse idea describes it's a
particular mathematical formalism it's
not exactly the same as
the one
the thing that i just described because
that is independent of the idea of such
a multiverse
so uh what i described is a way to look
at the universe as something like in
evolving fractals you have a generator
function that produces all the possible
generator function by just enumerating
them and just executing them in parallel
and as a result you get a time space and
matter and structure
matter is basically the structure that
is evolving in this phase and
is propelled along it and space is a set
of locations that you can discern that
can contain information that is
discernible and the ways that the
information can travel between these
locations
and uh
yeah
so you're saying that we can produce
some subsets that are causally closed
and then there are others that don't
influence us at all and to us whoever
lives within this causally closed place
so you know what i mean they are
constantly looping back to us so
you send a signal into the universe this
uni signal is going to influence certain
things and as a result you you get
feedback from this right you push a
certain thing and you see the results of
what you pushed because photons are
bounced off that thing that you are
pushing and uh there is a limit to that
that is a
visible universe right
if something goes uh beyond the region
from which light can reach us it's
it no longer has a causal influence to
us and the multiverse theory is that uh
the there is not just this boundary uh
in very very large distance but there is
a boundary next to us
where we do things that uh lead to
information uh
flowing away from us and not coming back
to us still there is a conservation of
information this conservation of
information is that we can always
basically in some sense figure out what
we did because all the influences that
matter get back to us
and of course
the there is a little bit of a tautology
in there if we are producing things in
the universe with our actions that in
some sense would generate new
information that goes away from us and
doesn't come back we would never know
about it
and in some sense the multiverse is an
inevitable description
of such a universe that
where the collapse of the wave function
can happen in multiple ways where are
the other ways happening where are they
going
why is it that we only experience this
particular collapse of the wave function
and the multiverse theory is a possible
answer to that
and there are other possible answers to
that um one could be that uh for
instance the
collapse of the wave function is
deterministic uh in this in a certain
sense and that is uh
means that uh it's influenced by things
that are non-local
and that we cannot pinpoint